and here we go we're going to begin with
this america's unrelenting coronavirus
pandemic it's caused more than 12
million infections
3 million plus in november alone now a
new model predicts it could soon get
even worse than that another
169 000 cases were reported yesterday
that model published in the journal
scientific reports estimates
that the u.s could reach 20 million
cases by the end of january
under the current social distancing
efforts we're seeing airports full of
travelers right now
ignoring the cdc's recommendations to
stay home
for thanksgiving the tsa says it
screened more than 3
million people between friday and sunday
sunday was the busiest day at our
airports since the middle of
march new jersey governor phil murphy
warns the next few months in his state
will be
brutal as coveted cases rise he's
encouraging everyone to celebrate
thanksgiving with
only their immediate family governor
murphy joins us now
governor murphy good morning to you i
love talking to governors about
the crisis because really this has been
a state-led effort
to combat it additionally we are at an
interesting moment eight months in
we've kind of been here before with a
big surge how are you thinking about
things
this time around differently from when
you faced it in
april and may good to be with you tony
um well first of all we're at the front
end of a holiday season that comes one
after the other
in cold weather and that's a bad
combination
secondly there's a lot of pandemic
fatigue that we didn't have
in the spring thirdly a lot of the
transmission is in private settings
so yes are we taking surgical action you
bet you're closing indoor dining at 10
o'clock
uh limiting indoor gatherings to 10
persons uh
and other steps we've taken but we're
mostly pleading with people yeah
to do the right thing behind closed
doors celebrate with just your immediate
family and please
don't do it with grandma and grandpa
when you think back to
april and may the last time we had a
surge like this
you can't help but notice that you had
stayed home orders then and you don't
now
knowing what you know now about how to
combat this do you wish you had gone
easier then
or are you considering going harder now
still
no i think we we had no choice in the
spring this is something we knew
nothing about as a nation frankly as a
global health community
that's an asset today we know a lot more
this is not all bad news we're in for a
rough couple of months
and we gotta keep our guard up but we
know a lot more
we have a lot more capacities and the
vaccine
scene is real they are coming they'll be
safe they'll be efficacious but for the
next two to three months
uh we are in a in a tough war you made
the point that
uh there's always a trade-off between
the public health component of this and
then the business economy freedom
component of this and if you were to to
be more arduous with the restrictions on
business you would as you put it
be putting a bullet in their head but
you would consider it if there was
stimulus money from the federal
government
if you had a bill giving businesses
money
to stay closed if you had help from the
feds
would you be considering shutting things
down in the state of new jersey
we'd have more degrees of freedom
without question so if we see there's
transmission
for instance in restaurants we saw them
morphing into clubs
after 10 o'clock we took action so if we
see transmission we'll take action
whether the feds are supporting
financially or not
but if it's a close call on the margin
and you've got
federal stimulus in size that can help
these poor small business owners
restaurant owners
folks who are unemployed that gives you
more degrees of freedom
without question governor i want to talk
to you about a
incident i thought was very
disrespectful to you you were outside
dining with your family following the
rules eating outside
one of your constituents was i thought
vulgar disrespectful
i saw it happen to sarah huckabee when
she was with her family i think family
should be off limits
but i'm wondering how you all reacted to
that and are you surprised that this
thing has become so heated
about the mask to wear a mask not to
wear a mask that it now becomes
it's it's it's like uh chaos in the
streets
on some level yep yeah i mean gail
those are all good questions the
overwhelming amount of stress
i get some of this has been added to it
unnecessarily particularly around
masking yeah
there's no reason we should be having a
political discussion
about whether you're wearing a mask we
were dining outdoors uh
in in the middle of our meal i i'm a big
guy
i could take it my wife could take it
i'd prefer folks to be more civil and to
leave our kids out of this
but i completely get the stress the
stress levels are
exceptionally high you've lost a job
you've lost a business
you've lost a loved one i i can't blame
folks for being stressful i just
would preach that we got to try to find
ways to come together
hunker down this isn't forever and for
always we're we've got a tough few
months in front of us
but we're going to get through this we
just got to do it together i get the
stress i just don't like the disrespect
did you guys just continue eating or
what did you do
because she called me some choice words
i won't repeat it here yeah yeah from
the world of male anatomy
from the world of male anatomy yeah
exactly yeah we kept
eating a dinner and uh i'm a murphy so i
had a drink uh afterwards as well
but uh yeah listen it was unfortunate
the language was unacceptable i wish our
kids weren't sucked into it but
i get the stress you get it your kids
handled it well i have to say
i did governor murphy thank you very
much we appreciate it have a good
holiday
you too thanks for having me it is